Speaker 1: There's this guy named Michael Knowles
from the Daily Wire. Some of you know him as the
Daily Wire, third stringer behind Matt Walsh and
Ben SHAPIRO. Anyway, I've been on his show before.
I stopped going on his show because nothing
positive came from it. It doesn't doesn't
have a big enough audience that
it actually did anything for me.
But I would get a barrage of anti-Semitic messages
from his viewers that very same Michael Knowles
thought yesterday to say, you know what,
David Pacman is making up, that he's getting
anti-Semitic e-mails and threats as a result of
his tweet. Here is what Michael Knowles had to
say. And, of course, there's always this very
you know, his background is in acting. There's
always this overly dramatic acting that he's
doing. He's just so upset, so upset by my tweet.
Speaker 3: There was the most vile reaction
that I've seen to the shooting in Nashville
was from someone who's appeared on this show
actually as a liberal. But he's appeared on
this show. Yeah. And it's it's just so hideous.
Yeah, but and I bring it up not even just to.
Castigate this guy. Right. But but to show
you how wrong the libs thinking is, in fact.
Speaker 1: Our thinking is 1,000% right in
that the thoughts and the prayers do nothing.
And the Republicans don't want to do anything
other than that. The thinking is 100% right.
Speaker 3: How pervasive this kind of vile
thinking is, but also how wrong it is. Sure.
David Pacman. Yeah. Tweeted out, quote, Very
surprising that there would be a mass shooting
at a Christian school given that lack of prayer is
often blamed for these horrible events. It isn't
possible they weren't praying enough or correctly.
Speaker 1: Isn't this just like, obvious?
Speaker 3: Despite being a Christian school?
Speaker 1: Yeah. They sent thoughts and prayers.
And there's a shooting at a place where people
are praying. Obviously, the elected officials
who only send thoughts and prayers are horrible
people unwilling to actually do anything to solve
this problem. What's so complicated about that?
Speaker 3: And that is the most vile tweet I've
ever read. Can you imagine? Has he ever does he.
Speaker 1: Remember when Trump was on Twitter,
the most vile tweet? So the hyperbole
is going a little far, I have to say.
Speaker 3: And Twitter is a cesspool.
For the most vile kinds of speech you can imagine.
Speaker 1: That's true. Now, that's true.
Speaker 3: If you have any kind of public
profile at all, you say you've seen plenty
of vile stuff directed at you or.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Much of it that
is much of it from his audience.
Speaker 3: The single most vile
tweet I have ever read.
Speaker 1: Really,
It must be very sheltered.
Speaker 3: He ended up deleting it,
but he didn't apologize.
Speaker 1: Well, now, I mean,
people deliberately misconstrued it to send
a hate mob against me. Why would I apologize?
It's accurate. The thoughts and prayers didn't
prevent the shooting and are elected officials
need to do more and they're unwilling to.
Speaker 3: In fact, he played the victim. He said,
all right, too many anti-Semitic attacks and
threats to my family. I've delete the tweet.
So we wanted this. One. No one saw any of
these alleged anti-Semitic attacks. But
what a what a joker. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, anyway,
the anti-Semitic attacks. Check a couple of things
on this. I don't want to, like, highlight too many
of these anti-Semitic attacks and threats
because it just feels more of them. But now
that someone is prominent, as Michael Knowles
is saying, suggesting there are no such things,
I have to at least say something about it. First
of all, check out the comments. Just look through
the comments. I won't even put them up. Check
out the comments on the video I did about this.
The video wherein I said, a million people are
angry at me. My tweet pissed off a million people.
Just scroll through the comments. Half of the
comments are overtly anti-Semitic comments.
It's like a neo-Nazi KKK meeting in the comments.
To the point where YouTube contacted me and said,
listen, this is like beyond just reporting
individual comments because it's just it's all
anti-Semitic. YouTube doesn't know how to handle
the comments on my YouTube channel because they
are so anti-Semitic. And I don't know what Michael
Knowles would accept as proof. Check out my inbox
again. A thousand of these and also some sent to
family members whose contact info these people
found. I'm just going to give you three examples
again, because I want to show you that these are
very real, but also not spend all day showing you
these. One person wrote to me calling me a filthy
anti-white k-word k-word for Jew, which I don't
know if it's allowed on radio, so I'm not going
to say it and says you're a rat faced anti-white
k-word who belongs in Israel. I've been to Israel
once for ten days. Someday Jews will have their
citizenship stripped and they will be banned from
holding positions in American government, media,
academia and law. White people are simply sick
of your Jewish degeneracy, and it's time for Jews
to pack up and leave. This is one of a thousand.
Michael Knowles says these don't exist. Here's
reality. Michael Knowles lives in a fantasy world.
We have reality and we have fantasy here. Michael
knows lives in fantasy. This is the reality. One
out of a thousand that I got. Second one again,
just just a sampling. Jewish from someone who goes
by groper. Way to mark the murder of Christians.
F-ing K-word. K-word for Jews. Okay. And third.
F-you dumb C-word often used for women. Have fun
in hell, Jew boy. Christ is king. Holocaust didn't
happen, by the way. Okay. I could do a live stream
all day just reading these. They come in faster
than they can be read. If you look at Twitter,
YouTube, my email inbox, Facebook and Instagram.
Michael Knowles says the anti-Semitic messages
don't exist. They come in at a rate of more
than one every few seconds. Okay. So that's the
truth. But Michael Knowles and others want you to
think there are none. And by the way, I stopped
doing his show. Because every time I was on it,
I would get anti-Semitic emails. It just
wasn't worth it because it wasn't helping me
build my audience. It was only generating hate.
These people are truly dangerous and they're
depraved. But after the break, I'm going
to tell you the good of the last 24 hours.